i think as long as i have a producer
just sub
in the new city whatever the new city is
every day
i can keep the exact same structure in
my show which is
democrats are burning another city and
today's city is spin the wheel
louisville louisville yes they're
burning down that city this time not
because a cop
used force justly or unjustly most of
the time the vast majority of the time
turns out
cops are justly using force but that
doesn't matter they always
riot over it anyway this is not because
a cop
used force this is not because a cop got
off the hook
for using force justly or unjustly
right now the radical left is burning
down louisville and shooting people and
killing people trying to kill people
because a cop was only charged with a
class
d felony for using force
rather than a more serious felony the
cop didn't even get off the hook
for using force which may well have been
justified
but they what do they want to do i guess
they want them to be hanged drawn and
quartered
this comes back to the brianna taylor
case which has been
probably in a way even more than george
floyd the central issue of the past
six months of blm riots it's the one
where they say say her name
brianna taylor now of course everyone's
saying her name so i don't know why they
have to say say that her name
but the case of brianna taylor is
brianna taylor was dating
and very very possibly working with this
drug trafficker
and there are people who have gone on
the record to say she was working with
the drug trafficker
and this drug trafficker may have been
using her identity and her
address to deal on these drugs she's
with
the drug trafficker in the apartment the
cops get a no knock warrant to search
the place
so this is why no knock warrants where
you don't have to knock and say who you
are before you go in
that's why they've been a hot button
political issue but it's it's pretty
stupid that they've become a hot button
political issue
because the issue here was the cops
didn't use a no-knock warrant the cops
knocked which allowed this drug
trafficker to grab a gun
and start shooting at the cops so then
the cops shoot
back and sadly this this guy's
girlfriend brianna taylor goes down in
the scuffle
we don't know totally her involvement in
the drug trafficking operation we just
know that she's
we know at the very least she's involved
with this guy we don't know
exactly to what extent so what happens
yesterday
or two yes it was yesterday that this
grand jury report came out
so hard the days all blend together
because the riots happened
so quickly now actually the riots were
about to preempt the grand jury
decision there was already a state of
emergency declared in louisville
because they they knew that anything
that happens in this case is going to
cause people to go out in the street
so this police officer gets charged
on three counts of wanton endangerment
in the first degree
in the death of brianna taylor this this
sergeant is brett hankins henkeson
and so while he was charged with wanton
endangerment the first degree
he was not charged with the more serious
felony
uh related to homicide and so this is a
class d felony he could serve five years
in prison bayless said at fifteen
thousand
dollars sounds about right it might be
even a little bit harsh i don't know i
haven't seen
the details of the case but i haven't
seen any evidence
that this cop was some murderer going
around because he's a racist and he
really hates black ladies the riots
begin riders in louisville shoot two
cops
as of now as of now i'm sure i'm sure
more violence will be to come
this is not spontaneous this is not a
grassroots uprising
this is not a creed occur of a of an
oppressed people
who are finally rising up now this is a
highly
planned event in keeping with a
highly planned insurrection and a very
well-funded
insurrection going on around the country
planned out and executed by people
who want to destroy the united states
and america
united states of america who are very
open about it by the way i hope you
enjoyed that short segment from the
michael knowles show be sure to check
out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you